well you know one of my
first videos that it was called life of
an entrepreneur okay
if you look at the life of an
entrepreneur guess what car is in it a
red ferrari
okay so when i posted that video
everybody said oh he probably ran it
this far i'm like damn these people
think i rented this ferrari
okay i mean it was yours your own you
owned it i had it for three years i had
that ferrari for three years i sold the
ferrari a year ago i had it for three i
drove it every day i sold it with 25 000
miles
you sold it last year i sold the last
year yeah so for me
when i had my aventador i drove it every
day i put 10 000 miles on it i just sold
my aventador
i put 20 000 miles on it i drive my
exotics i don't buy it and put it
except the next one i'm buying that
one's not gonna be driven a lot but when
that comes that comes what's the point
moral the story if you go through my
pictures on instagram
i don't know how many pictures you're
going to see with cars maybe five
maybe six does it work 100
i will tell you it 100 works if you own
a ferrari
and you pull up to a place that you want
to network
and you pull up in a red ferrari you're
going to get different kind of attention
than if you pull up in an s500 it's just
automatic everyone's going to look at it
so yes
it's you know chauvinistic whatever you
want to call it
but when trump goes to speak in north
carolina
and there's a plane in the back not a
air force one but it says trump
pretty sick you know it's kind of like
call this man broke it's ten thousand
dollars an hour to fly that thing so
you think he's broke if he flies from
florida to new york and back that's a
sixty thousand dollar flight just on gas
you think he's broken 60 000
the average person spends 400 to go from
florida to new york back and forth this
guy's spending 60 000
to go on a plane like that you got to
know that people sit there and say
this freaking guy owns a plane and it's
got his name on it
so there is an element that it works
only this is the part i was going to
with this
he's a great marketer he's a great
marketer but the reason why it works for
him
is because of what we talked about with
stink and ray charles
he's been doing this for decades yeah
kardashian
so you can put a picture with a ferrari
but if that picture doesn't show up five
years from now
you may have been a fraud you can put a
picture of your house
but if you rented that house everybody
wants to know what happened to that
house 15 years later
and you're forgotten i will tell you
there is nothing
there is nothing worse
than being forgotten about it doesn't
matter if your grandfather
if your grandkids and your kids don't
want to see you anymore it's one of the
most painful things you'll ever have
if you don't get an invitation to a
wedding in your grandfather
i mean that's like a night no pain is
going to be more difficult than that
right so
have you experienced that uh uh have i
experienced i experienced on a smaller
scale i experienced on a smaller scale
more on the night club scene because i
was the guy that was you know you wanted
to go to the parties with me and
you know the girls and all that other
stuff and then one moment
i decided to you know get my act
together and stop being uh uh
the guy that i was and i wanted to
change some of my habits i was partying
way too much i was going to vegas every
other weekend i'm at nightclub six
nights a week i'm at night clubs and
you know women here women there and one
day i just said i want to drop this
habit because i'm broke
my dad had a heart attack i went to the
hospital and i saw this man at ucla
medical center on his deathbed lost
you know nearly 40 pounds and i said to
myself we got to make some changes here
man this is not going to happen i went
in my car
sat on my ford focus i was the guy that
had the nice suv i take everybody to the
club see i'm on my ford focus
crying like a little baby at 23 years
old i said
you're partying every night your dad's
about to die he works at a 99 cent store
and this man sacrificed everything to
bring you to america and you want to go
party every night
what are you doing get your act together
next day i came to look on my face
changed
i went to work but i was forgotten about
at the nightclubs
i was forgotten about i was no longer
the cool guy i was the square guy
all you want to do is read business
books what a freaking boring guy you are
but that's kind of a cool thing but it's
not though at the beginning when you're
going
through it at the beginning when you're
going through it it's not because
there's short-term pain and most people
believe it or not if that was so easy a
lot of people would do it
but most people eventually hate the
comment people make when they say
you know what bobby man i miss the old
you
you've changed most people cannot handle
that compliment they don't know it's a
compliment
they take it as it is in that moment you
don't know what's going on because you
haven't still proven that you're going
to be successful
when i was going through the phase i
wasn't i wasn't that 49 000
so people like what are you doing come
on down we're missing you and
everybody's asking about you and it's
like oh it's pad you know
so you kind of are forgotten about and
when that happens
you know you you kind of start thinking
about what really matters in your life
and
then eventually you get to the mature
stage where you say well really that
stuff didn't matter to me anyways
but when you're in the middle of it you
don't know because you don't know if the
price is worth it
you don't know if the price is worth it
so danny when you're in the middle
and you're going through paying the
price and
you have not yet proven to yourself okay
meaning nobody yet knows you don't know
if this 80 hours a week you're putting
into working is gonna work
right how many guys you know pay the
price of playing football 24
7 and then make it this close to the nfl
they don't make it they're working out
of starbucks
that's a very good so you're right there
you can go smoke weed with that girl and
party and do a couple lines
because you don't know for a fact if
you're going to get into the nfl and
you're tempted she's the one you always
wanted to get together and now she wants
to get together with the unbringer girl
with you
that's some experience do you want to
really give that up and at one moment
you're in that tipping point you may not
make it in the nfl so you're kind of
like well i'm not going to make it
anyways
why am i going to do it i'm not going to
make a build a real business anyways how
do i know i'm going to do it so
it's in those moments where we screw up
so yes
there is nothing more painful than being
forgotten about
when it happens many of these guys that
were cool at one point
with their ferrari pictures they will be
forgotten about if there's no substance
how do you feel about
making content
for your audience versus making content
about
what speaks to you personally or what
you're personally
interested in yeah so i do bodybuilding
because i wanted to be mr olympia before
so it's very easy to me bodybuilding
because
uh anything from 1990 until mid-2000
i know all the bodybuilders and i'm very
good friends with phil heath we're
pretty much talking every single week
good friend of mine i advise him on a
couple things that he does so
bodybuilding interview for me is very
easy
mob interviews very easy for me why i
watched all the stories i read all the
books
i know all the things that i came up
reading about the things that happened
with mob so
whatever you do that there's interest in
you
when you do that interview the audience
is gonna feel it whatever you do
you gotta chase the views or do you
chase just what you're interested in
even if it doesn't bring in views do you
focus more on business
the business side of it the numbers all
that stuff or do you
just you know whatever follow your
passion or your dream or whatever it is
if you're doing it just to have fun
you're doing it if you're doing it
because
you know it's a business model and
you're
selling stuff through it then that's a
different thing if you're doing it
because
right you know it's so different for
everybody on youtube i mean you got
these six-year-old kids seven-year-old
kids that are unpacking toys
you know making 22 million a year kid's
name is ryan you know he's got this
channel that all he does is open up
lego toys or different toys he's a 22
million
year earner seven year old kid i mean
who's doing it him or his parents his
parents
there are so many ways to leverage
technology today but it's all on what
you're solving for
and you know many times while you're
doing what you're doing
you may not even know it for the first
two three four five years right
five years later you may say you know
what this is going to turn into a bit
concrete all of a sudden cut up 10
million subscribers
now you're getting sponsors are coming
to you and saying hey what can we do to
get you have no idea what it's going to
go from there now you need advisors now
you got attorneys
now you got agents managers and i got
people come up to you saying hey we want
to use them different ways what do you
think about this now you got
opportunities coming your way
then you really will be making decisions
in a different way next thing you know
i'm on patrick
david's level well listen everybody has
a different
the biggest challenge is you know when
you look at the game you you said
something very interesting here do you
solve for views
or do you solve for what you want to do
what your passion is right i mean
originally when you're coming out it's
it's
unfortunately when you're smaller a lot
of times people compare right oh my god
look at that guy
like when we were first getting started
it's like oh we only have 100
subscribers oh my gosh we suck nobody
likes our content
this must not be good then you're like
well you we got one video got 300 views
this is amazing you know and then
who are these 300 people that are
watching this video then you get a
thousand views 2000 views and then the
moment you forget
what the audience thinks about the
content you're creating
that's when you start winning moment you
forget the moment you forget that
i really don't care if you like it or
not i'm enjoying
absolutely i really don't care if you
uh like when i went into bodybuilding
interviews i got to tell you i got a lot
of people that hated the fact that i was
doing bodybuilding interviews
they said why are you doing bodybuilding
interviews this is an entrepreneurial
website i said i love bodybuilding
um you try to keep them they try to keep
you in your box you got it so so
you yourself you you have momentum right
now you're about to get big momentum
all of a sudden you get to five ten
million subs you're one of these guys
that are bigger channels you know
people are going to try to keep you in a
box you got to play to what you want to
play
because that's how you want people over
in the first place
you